commercials have 80 billion dollars in  ad spend a year mainly with the Fortune  500 companies those companies are now  especially with a looming recession  coming finally starting to understand  that when they run a commercial on a  sitcom or a reality show on cable that  they are taking good cash and lighting  it on fire and throwing it in the  garbage I believe for the entrepreneurs  in this room there's a 24 to 36 month  window when the getting is good it's not  as good as it was four years ago but I  believe three to four or five years it's  going to be really not good if 40  billion or 20 billion comes into Tick  Tock and Facebook and Instagram not if  when that money comes in everything I'm  passionately communicating to right now  will not be as easy I have been the Pied  Piper for social for 13 years and I can  tell you because I'm in the trenches the  biggest companies in the world are about  to reallocate their money much more into  social than television